dernière ligne droite pour beaucoup
d'étudiants réunionnais marine termine
ainsi son dernier oral de bts
communication
de quoi se mettre sur son 31 pour marine
mais aussi pour son assistante de vie
scolaire au lycée leconte de lisle donc
c'est ma classe de bts comme habituelles
voilà ça y est c'est mon dernier jour du
passé mon dernière orale ce matin il ya
quoi il ya 10 minutes en fait ce furent
intenses et du coup voilà donc j'imagine
pas cela dit j'espère valider un bts
communication dans quelques semaines
atteinte de maladie génétique depuis
l'enfance s'est accompagnée que marine a
toujours progressé dans sa scolarité
avec quatre petites choses qui sont
mises en place
bah pourront finalement de faciliter la
vie et faire en sorte que ma scolarité
comme tout autre élève donc yann à l
état roumain
quels sont les avsi qui se partagent mon
emploi du temps
je bénéficie des clés d'ascenseur prix
là je viens vendre du bip du portail
aussi pour que le blue chauffeur du bus
qui se garaient l'intérieur du lycée
quand ils me déposait continuant experts
est pareil je bénéficie dès que
l'infirmerie pour pas pour j'en ai
besoin ont tous les établissements que
j'ai fréquenté oui ça a été comme ça à
chaque fois il ya eu la présence marins
des du maine toute façon à ce que je
puisse être un maximum autonome et puis
là l'adaptation entre guillemets des
locaux pour que je puisse circuler sans
problème
et comme chaque jour depuis 17 ans un
transport adapté au handicap de marine
est mise en place par le conseil
départemental
parce que c'était une fille depuis tout
petit non ça va franchement le service
est agréable ça a toujours été la même
chose moi depuis tout petit va je donne
mon emploi du temps à la rentrée et et
après pour les paniers les peurs et
vient nous chercher à le matin avant une
demi heure avant pour déposer au lycée
ou à l'école et par plus de 1500 enfants
sont transportés chaque année par la
direction des transports et des routes
du conseil départemental un service de
l'ombre qui prend tout son sens dans
chaque projet d'élèves
ensemble c'est vrai que ça rend service
ça permet de l'enfant de d'avoir une
indépendance d'être transportés comme
tous les autres enfants qui prennent le
bus par exemple elle est transportée
deux fois par jour c'est-à-dire à
l'entrée de l'école et à la sortie de
l'école
une jeune fille épanouie qui surmonte ou
les freins de sa scolarité
après la validation de son diplôme elle
ne compte pas s'arrêter là
on va y arriver hélas son objectif son
but c'est de se départir en métropole 2
d'être étudiante comme toffin la plupart
des étudiants réunionnais ils font ici
donc elle va partir faire ses études
là-bas comme elle m'a dit maman moins
diplômés là bas donc il faut bien aller
chercher mon diplôme
peut-être qu'elle reviendra après je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas moi moi moi
moi je suis ravi de son de son objectif
coin de son avenir et je je n'en doute
pas que ça va marcher
une personne valide elle fait ces choses
là donc je vois pas pourquoi je ne
jouerai pas tout simplement pour moi
c'est pas une question de pas de limites
voilà c'est un grand mot pas ces grandes
questions au jeu complètement je me vois
pas aisé pas certes je fais des projets
servi j'ai des envies et tous mais je
serai là où le vent me mènera parce que
je n'ai pas envie d'être déçu tout
simplement donc j'ai envie de mener mes
projets professionnels a bien ça se
passera comme ça se passera
et je ferai ma petite vie est finie et
là où je devrais finir